our aim was to demonstrate how the
world's democracies are ready and able
to address the world's toughest problems
offering solutions
and backing them up with concrete action
the g7 will combine our strengths and
expertise
to defeat covid minimize the risk of
another pandemic
and build back better fairer and greener
for the benefit of all alongside our
partners the g7 is now engaged
in the biggest and fastest vaccination
program
in history designed to protect the whole
world by the end
of next year my fellow leaders agreed to
supply developing countries
with another billion doses either
directly or through other channels
of which 100 million will come from the
uk
the world's most popular vaccine was
developed here and the express purpose
of the deal between
the british government oxford university
and astrazeneca
was to create an inoculation that would
be easy
to distort to store quick to distribute
and available at cost price or zero
profit
to protect as many people as possible
the results are becoming clearer every
day over 500 million
oxford astrozenica vaccines have been
administered in
168 countries so far accounting for 96
of the doses distributed to developing
nations by kovacs
the global alliance that the uk helped
to establish
with every passing hour people are being
protected across the world and lives
saved
by the formidable expertise that the uk
was able to assemble but all the efforts
of this country
and of many others no matter how
generous
and far sighted would be futile in the
face
of another lethal virus that might
escape our efforts so the g7 has agreed
to support a global pandemic radar
to spot new pathogens before they begin
to spread allowing
immediate containment and in case a new
virus gets through anyway
our scientists will embark on a mission
to develop the ability to create new
vaccines
treatments and tests in just 100 days
compared to the 300 required for covid
even as we persevere against this virus
my
fellow leaders share my determination to
look beyond today's crisis
and build back better greener and fairer
if we can learn anything from this
tragedy we have at least been given a
chance to break with the past
and do things better and do them
differently
this time as our economies rebound we
must avoid the mistakes
we made after the financial crash of
and ensure that everyone benefits from
the recovery
the surest way of our future prosperity
is to design
fair and open rules and standards for
the new frontiers
of the global economy so the g7 will
devise a fairer tax system for global
corporations reversing the race to the
bottom
and strive to ensure that new technology
serves as a force for prosperity
and hope strengthening freedom and
openness
my fellow leaders will act as one
against an
increasing injustice the denial of an
education
to millions of girls across the world by
working to get another 40 million girls
into school by 2025. i'm happy to say
that the g7 agreed to provide more than
half
of the 5 billion sought by the global
partnership for education
to transform the prospects of millions
of children in developing countries
and 430 million pounds and will come
from
the uk our duty to future
generations compels us to protect
our planet from catastrophic climate
change
and every country in the g7 has promised
to achieve
net zero by 2050 wiping out our
contribution to global warming from that
date onwards and to achieve that target
we will halve our carbon emissions by
compared with 2010 levels the g7
resolved to end
any government support for unabated
coal-fired
powers generation overseas and
increase and improve climate finance
between now
and 2025. we will consecrate
30 percent of our land and sea to nature
protecting fast areas in all their
abundance and diversity
of life giving millions of species the
chance to recover
from the ravages of recent decades
and it is precisely because safeguarding
safeguarding
our planet requires global action that
the g7
will offer developing countries a new
partnership
the build back better world to help
construct
new and clean gr and green
infrastructure
in a way that is transparent and
environmentally
responsible there is no contradiction
between averting climate change and
creating highly skilled
and well-paid jobs both in our country
and around
the world we can and will achieve both
by means of a green industrial
revolution at home and green
infrastructure aboard abroad